the airport in Buffalo New York remains
closed and so are most of its streets
while the death toll from the Christmas
blizzard keeps rising at least 31 deaths
are now blamed on the weather in Erie
County alone the epicenter of this
historic winter storm that brought more
than four feet of snow City officials
have gone from search and rescue to
clearing the roads and they warned that
the work is far from over Tara Lynch of
our buffalo affiliate wivb is tracking
the massive recovery effort
with nearly 50 inches of snow covering
the streets the City of Buffalo is
facing the next challenge in this
historic storm
attempting to clear the roads
emergency crews are working tirelessly
to get the snow ice and hundreds of
abandoned vehicles off the road National
Guardsman Matthew Waldman is on the
front lines there's a lot of stranded
cars a lot of stranded trucks semis a
couple trees onto buildings lots of
buildings completely covered in snow
Waldman became a HomeTown hero this
weekend helping Buffalo residents TJ
Thomas and Denisha King get to the
hospital safely to deliver their fourth
child after their car was completely
snowed in in my mind I was just hoping
that she was okay and I would be able to
get her to the hospital for her to
deliver the baby and the baby be able to
recover from the delivery safely
but not all residents have experienced
Miracles like that over the past few
days with the dangerous road conditions
Linda Kaczynski hasn't been able to
drive to her father's house just a few
miles away to check on him my brother
actually walked there two days in the
middle of the blizzard
all bundled up
Extraordinary Measures and an
extraordinary storm that's taken its
toll on a community that's no stranger
to snow
for CBS Mornings in Buffalo Tara Lynch